everybody knows about Sinclair and
there's xat there's the lovely zx80 and
a lot of people know about his story
followed in the next year there's X 81
but there was a machine that went before
it wasn't from Sinclair as a company
wasn't from Sinclair researcher from a
company called science of Cambridge and
it's the mk14 and it looks exactly like
that pretty basic stuff not even case on
this one so this came out in 1977
I mean 1977 you've gotta realize this is
a couple of years before Blues SAT two
or three years before this was launched
so computing home computing personal
computing was very much in its infancy
as you can see and this isn't a great
deal more than a calculator in some ways
but it's the beginning of everything in
terms of Sinclair and what they would do
later on and there's a nice little story
that goes along with it so as with many
things sometimes the story's not quite
what you'd expect it to be they take
this magazine here
computing today computing today number
one was actually part of ETI electronics
today international November 1978 this
was dated so very very early on but in
there is an advert for the MK 14 this
thing was 39 pound 95 to by-pass 8% b8e
250 pound in today's money approximately
taking into account inflation so it
sounds really cheap but really it wasn't
and I can put that into context so 3995
for one of these here a very early copy
of personal computer world 78 same kind
of error at the back we have a machine
for example the Exedy sorcerer brilliant
machine but this guy is very happy as
you can see is a database theta 2k
computer I want you to spend less than a
thousand pound my sorcerer cost me 950
yeah 950 pound is about five and a half
grand in today's money you know and yeah
if you had that kind of money you would
be doing that kind of thing on the
picture seed one there's it surprisingly
at 1674 for that machine that's then
money not today's money so that's even
more expensive they were used in
education they were use for research you
know that these machine we don't have to
realize these were the my
crow computers so mainframes and mineus
they were they were hundreds of
thousands of hours of bite back then you
know millions of pounds in today's money
so these were you know relatively cheap
relative being the operative word there
but very very expensive most people
couldn't afford these these kind of
things so sinclair as always wanted to
bring machines out to broke that price
barrier and not just by a bit by lot the
mk14 was obviously vastly cut down from
any of those other machines that are out
there you had this very very simple
touch keyboard there an LED display so
basically a calculator display you can
only do sort of 7-segment digits with
that it had 256 bytes of RAM because
that's not even kilobytes a quarter of a
Killa bye
so very very limited ram but then you
know with a keyboard like that how much
data you really going to type into these
things how much did you need it was an 8
bit processor it had 12 bits of address
space then you could take a bit further
with an extra four bits as well but
you'd have to software program that but
it was pretty limited but it was a
machine that you could buy for 3995 you
could own this thing and you could write
the code that you wanted to write so how
did Sinclair and I'll say Chris curry at
the time how did they come about with
actually making this as a product there
was a guy called Ian Williamson and he
come up with an idea for a microcomputer
kit and he saw the scamp design so we
have to look at the main chip the main
shipping that there is the processor
this is the scamp processor it's
actually written SC / MP and it stands
for simple cost-effective or one word
microprocessor two words another press
isn't only long word these days anyway
SCMP but it got known as the scamp
and it was an impressive little
processor made by national semiconductor
in Williams has seen the various designs
out there and this is a development
system for the SCMP and we also have
quite a rare intro kit that you could
buy this kit and make your own SCMP
based system national semiconductor
produce this so that people in the
industry could make their designs around
it and they had something called a
reference design so they had a circuit
diagram in Williamson produce this
again based on that original design took
it to Clive and Chris and said I've got
an idea for a product that you might be
interested in making and as the story
goes we do have a video on our youtube
channel which is an interview with in
Williamson that so you can get this from
the horse's mouth but he showed this to
the guys and they were interested very
much interested Sinclair was probably
more interested in the future of this
what it could become because it was very
very basic but Chris thought yes this
could be a product so they said yeah
this is we interested in that that's an
interesting thing that we might be able
to market but when they went to national
semiconductor and said okay we want to
buy a load of your scamp chips national
semiconductor said all what you what do
you do with those and they explained it
and they said well actually you know
we've already got the reference design
you know we could supply you with those
chips and the reference design you
basically just make that as a kit and
sell it so Chris had to sort of go back
with you know tell gratuities legs and
say - Ian well actually you know really
sorry I know we've we've shook on it but
we're actually going to go with national
semiconductor because they've given us a
fantastic deal so we don't need your
design thank you very much jog on this
guy's invented a design for computer but
there's one already existing yeah it was
only based on the reference designs of
national semiconductor but what it done
is he'd foreseen this idea that actually
you know the design is basically there
you can build upon this and actually
there's a lot of people that might like
to make this kit so the it's the idea
the initial idea came for me in that
this could be a product so that didn't
kind of work out free and sadly however
you know he would then go on to write
the menu along with Rodney dome there
was money to be made in creating the
manual and writing on the books for it
as well so other books were produced
about programming the machine and that
kind of thing I think we've got there
you go understanding micro processors
were the mk14 in Williamson a bloody
doubt both of who are trustees of the
museum I should say so yeah from the
original design and that's the kit that
you could buy you can see that there are
quite big similarities you've got the
same chip the original ceramic chip
there whereas these ones got the plastic
dips same kind of memory and then you
have a display here an LED display with
a keyboard well that looks pretty
similar to me so you can see that
progression on from the development kits
through to the board that was finally
produced and sold so this doesn't have
the processor in it the process is there
you have this prototyping area so what
you can do is you can put any components
you like there or wire them up and then
to program it you would put your board
into there you have different boards
with different expansions RAM or various
other i/o that kind of thing and you
could program it and make it do what you
want so this is the development system
and they gave you all the supporting
material yeah so the programming manuals
there so you would have your manual and
you would learn about the entire
instruction set so again you need what
needs to be remembered here is that we
are programming in assembly language in
a machine code so you are typing in
hexadecimal numbers here that represent
those commands so at this time Chris
Currie was at some size of Cambridge and
was really in charge of this product
project so later on when Chris was at a
call interestingly we have an acorn
system one this similar same kind of
calculator display their hex keypad
different chip this one uses a six 502
which would be the processor that their
next machines would use the BBC micro or
the Assam and that kind of thing but you
know it just shows how everything starts
somewhere so the system won't again a
very rare machine starting very very
basic type in you know assembly language
code in and and even that you know you
think that assembly language would be a
very high low level language that a lot
of people wouldn't do however if we take
a look at home computing games programs
on page 68 a knife for the MK 14 so here
we have a program listing for the MK 14
and it you can see it's the assembly
language code but that's the hex that
you would type in so memory location
of20 you would type in C for Oh a and
that would be effectively
ldx conway's game and yeah so but it's
not really a game it's more of a
simulation but that you know the machine
could play this kind of this basic game
you could play other games on it you
know the simple number games that you
could do trying to work out what they
this is oh there some are 81 so in 1981
and people were still writing code for
the MK 14 that was released in 77 so
these things had a reason
life I'm not sure if anybody did today
but who knows somebody probably did a
lot of people would were buying these
things as the kit so I have another
thing over here to show you this is
extremely rare let's move that out there
so if you'd ordered one of these things
this is what you get so this is an
unboxing of omen K 14 this probably
doesn't happen very much online this is
a completely unmade kit as it would have
been delivered so part of this was the
construction process in the first place
getting the manual getting the circuit
diagram understanding what all the
components do soldering them into their
place on the board soldering all of
these connections I don't know how many
there are there's a good couple of
hundred there so you'd sold all your
components in place and if you've done
it well we've got resistors there
capacitors and things crystal if you've
got it well it will work and you could
then start to program it really good
menu with it that had we've got greatest
common devisor software post delayed
digital alarm clock random noise decimal
to hex so you know there are lots of
things you could get it to do there's
even a monitor listing there and
interestingly the chip had an inbuilt
you are so it had a serial
communications actually built into the
chip so it was possible interconnects
out to a another device to then see the
output rather than just needing to rely
on that very very small calculator
display so there was lots of things you
could do and lot of this is just demo
software just to show you the ideas
between behind programming how you can
use memory locations so machine code
what you're doing is you're saying take
this memory location move it into the
processor adds something to it move it
back to a memory location very very
simple step language so that was defined
as kind of programming at the bare metal
you know you were talking directly to
the chips nothing in between so you knew
every single instruction and what it was
for and why it was there two concerns
chips directly so that give you a really
good understanding of program computers
and if you understood how to do this you
can apply that's pretty much to any
processor the the commands might change
but ultimately it's the same logical
thinking process so you know you could
type in those things those programs and
get them to run but also it has to be
remembered that on
the output here you've got a port
exposing the address and data bus and
various control lines and things and you
could then have it controlling other
things this was the kind of the rise of
pub it's day you know you had address
lines there you would put on a dress
decoder and create yourself some i/o
space and that could be sort of an
address latch or data bus election you
could then store data in and have a
Elpis or 16 amperes I mean you wanted
same way input you could have a latch
that then read inputs so you've got some
IO control so from that these things
were then use for a number of purposes
one we have in the collection is a
machine over here vaguely looks a little
bit like an MK 14 we've got the same
calculator display there same kind of
hex pad but this is used for medical
research so this is just an MK 14 in a
big wooden box you see the MK 14 down
there you can see the expansion chip we
have a tape interface there and then we
have some other malarkey going on there
not quite sure what that is power supply
you can just plug into the mains the
power supply drops it down to about 8
volts for the board itself and this was
used for medical research and charleon
inputs and outputs monitoring and then
analyzing those results it'll be quite
feasible that you could find out what
somebody's reaction times is depend on
how much they're drunk yeah that would
be a good use of this this machine I
have no idea that's what it was useful
but hey I might use that now it's good
to say we don't we need to do some
research I think yeah absolutely
oh yeah but some but yeah so these had
genuine real world uses it might seem
that one of these things is pretty much
unusable but really not you know it was
ultimately usable if you wanted to
control something this could have done
it there's a real world used for it
where they've made the Box made it
portable and very usable but then other
people were just using it for their own
fun learnings how to code controlling
their Hornby railway I know people that
had done exactly that with it so yeah
loads of different things and yeah this
was sort of 77 this was before most
people were into the micro computers as
they were then so ahead of the curve
so sometimes he floppies wood dies he
often would make backup copies let's try
this one sounds more hopeful and so
there was this game called Lander